ich bin heute beim Synodalen Weg der
katholischen Kirche wo sich zwei Lager
gegenüberstehen hier Maria 1.0 die
Vertreter der reinen katholischen Lehre
und hier Maria 2.0 die sowas wie
Gleichberechtigung wollen ja die
Stimmung könnte bei Schalke Dortmund
nicht besser sein
Mutter Mama dürfen weitermachen
wie stehen sie denn dazu dass Frauen
geweiht werden wollen jetzt hier
ich glaube sie können schon an oder so
okay ich kann es auch anders formulieren
nee ich formuliert anders also dass
Frauen jetzt auch geweiht werden wollen
ist er wirklich Quatsch oder so ist es
jetzt haben wir auch die Forderung die
Gegenseite die Segnung von Homosexuellen
in Deutschland werden ja sogar Züge
gesegnet natürlich alles kann gesegnet
werden von der katholischen Kirche außer
Homosexuelle die sich lieben das ist ja
wieder
natürliche Union eine Sache die nicht
gesegnet gehört es gibt hier Segnungen
gesehen wie zwei ICE gekoppelt werden in
mein Name
dafür oder ja ich ich 5 € von mir wenn
jemand umbringen ist er jetzt schon ein
bisschen was anderes als wenn man
jemanden mit dem gleichen Geschlecht
liebt
[Musik]
schaue ich mir jetzt mal die großen
Reformen der katholischen Kirche an also
ich gemeinsam mit meinem Kameramann
Jesus
wir haben eigentlich gar nichts
geschlossen warum was ist denn passiert
wir haben nur beschlossen dass wir
anstatt was zu verändern prüfen ob wir
überhaupt was verändern wollen ich würde
sagen es bleibt der alte Männerbund nein
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein nein schon geil dass man
Bischof ist mega geil wenn man Bischoff
ist und ich habe ja die einzige Hoffnung
die ich noch habe ist tatsächlich der
Heilige Geist ist angeblichen Taube und
ich habe die Erfahrung dass Tauben auch
ab und zu mal jemand auf dem Kopf kacken
und ich wüsste auch schon welcher
wirklichen willkommen ist Opfer sein
könnte freue ich mich auch die sind ja
quasi eine Legende eine lebende Legende
genau super ja bei Ihnen auch in der
Sendung sind sie eigentlich gegen die
Weihe von Frauen weil Frauen einfach
nicht so gut vertuschen können wie
Männer
bekommen hier gerade hin und bin gar
nicht so ganz richtig gesund ich schau
mal reinkommen
und die Stufe 3 ist an und Sie haben
Sauerkraut drin weiß schon lange Gerd
und wenn das Ventil nicht ein bisschen
aufgemacht wird dann geht das Sauerkraut
an die Decke mein Bild
ein schönes Gleichnis
schade dass sie nicht mal irgendwann
geweiht werden und sowas in der Kirche
erzählen können ich stehe hier mit
Weihbischof Ansgar Puff Herr Puff wann
ist dieser Puff hier endlich so
reformiert dass ich alle Probleme mit
einem Puff verpuffen wo man sagen kann
endlich Ruhe im Puff ich mag meinen
Namen auch ja sie wollen anstoßen jetzt
hat der Papst ja schon Nein gesagt
der Papst hat nicht nein gesagt sondern
der lässt uns laufen erstmal ich hatte
stattdessen Geheimtipp für Sie
brandheiße Sache und zwar gibt es da so
eine ganz neue Gruppe die haben all das
was sie fordern schon umgesetzt nennt
sich die evangelische Kirche ah ja die
gute evangelische Kirche Evangelen da
laufen die Mitglieder ja auch weg aber
halt mit Frauen und mit Sex also
bei uns ohne Fahne und ohne Sex also sie
kommen rüber verstehe ich richtig oder
eine überzeugt
ich glaube eh nicht dass das hier gerade
noch jemand sieht Wetten lieber heute
show Fans wenn ihr das hier noch seht
schreibt in die Kommentare Gernot
Hassknecht schauspielerische Darbietung
hat mich zu Tränen gerührt und abonniert
gerne den Kanal danke
und die endcard macht ihr jetzt hinter
jedes Video klar auch wenn ich nicht
darin vorkomme